there has been a vicious battle going on
between epic games the creators of
fortnite and apple who are famous for
being
well apple and just recently a judge
made a decision that could shape the
future of fortnite and the app store
itself forever if you go to the app
store today you'll find millions of
games but over a year after its removal
you still won't find fortnite and now
you're unlikely to for a very long time
[Music]
look this kind of legal stuff is
interesting it can shape the entire
games industry but at times it can be
quite heavy reading so make sure you
subscribe to the score esports then
you'll see us break down all that stuff
into nice videos like this it's that
simple subscribe all right now before we
get into this you might be a bit
hesitant to watch a video that is about
fortnite but don't worry even if you
don't play it it doesn't matter this
battle is defining what a video game is
how micro transactions happen in games
and how games themselves are distributed
so to figure out where things went so
sour between these two companies we have
to go back to 2018. that's the year that
fortnite launched on the ios platform
which every app developer has to use if
they want to get their product into the
hands of apple users initially things
went incredibly well for epic within
five months of launch app store tracker
apptopia was reporting that fortnite had
reached 100 million downloads on the
platform and made over 160 million
dollars in in-app purchase revenue
things seemed to go well for a while but
epic got restless you see apple has a
policy when it comes to any transactions
that take place on the app store they
take 30
and apple's reasoning is simple here
it's their platform so they want a slice
of any pie that's being bought or sold
on it that 30 cut is actually pretty
standard in the industry steam does it
for their games and google does it too
for apps that have made over a million
dollars now while the vast majority of
developers have accepted this epic got
tired of having to share their fortnite
pie every time an ios user bought a new
skin pickaxe or emote so in august 2020
epic secretly introduced a new feature
into the ios version of fortnite that
would allow people to pay them directly
when purchasing v-books apple wouldn't
get a cut of any transaction that
happened this way they even announced a
mega drop where players could get a 20
discount if they purchased v books
directly from epic but said they
couldn't offer the same discount to
those who paid through apple or google's
payment methods because of the 30
cut they took i mean at first glance
this does look like a bit of a petty
squabble between big companies arguing
over the average person's cash and maybe
you'll only ever see it that way and
that's fair but these legal proceedings
have brought up some pretty interesting
documents from over the years for
example take this 2015 email from epic
games founder and ceo tim sweeney to
apple ceo tim cook stating that quote it
doesn't seem tenable for apple to be the
sole arbiter of expression and commerce
over an app platform approaching a
billion users and at the top there you
can see tim cook forwarding the email
and asking if tim sweeney was the guy at
one of their rehearsals that was six
years ago and over two years before
fortnite was released and it's not just
apple that tim's been arguing with
either in 2017 he spoke out against
steam for a similar reason arguing they
could be profitable with just an eight
percent cut from in-game transactions
instead of 30. it does seem like open
distribution has been a passion of tim
sweeney's and by extension epic games
for longer than this battle with apple
has been going on for but let's get back
to that battle shall we by sneaking this
update into fortnite epic games had
essentially circumvented apple's entire
app store business model and
unsurprisingly they were pretty pissed
on august 13th apple removed fortnite
from the app store epic then immediately
hit back by filing a lawsuit in which
they sought injunctive relief to allow
for fair competition in the 65-page
lawsuit epic laid out their complaint
that apple had monopolized the
distribution and monetization of
software such as fortnite then on august
28 2020 apple terminated epic's account
on the app store and with it users
abilities to download any of their games
in a statement apple said we are
disappointed that we have had to
terminate the epic games account on the
app store we have worked with the team
at epic games for many years on their
launches and releases the court
recommended the epic comply with the app
store guidelines while their case moves
forward guidelines they followed for the
past decade until they created this
situation epic has refused instead they
repeatedly submit fortnite updates
designed to violate the guidelines of
the app store this is not fair to all
other developers on the app store and is
putting customers in the middle of their
fight we hope that we can work together
again in the future but unfortunately
that is not possible today and in a move
of unquestionable pettiness apple also
made fortnite's rival pubg their
featured app of the day on the app store
they followed this up with a countersuit
of their own against epic claiming the
company had breached its contract with
the app store and that quote their
conduct threatened the very existence of
the ios ecosystem so the stage was set
in may 2021 the trial began and over the
course of three weeks it went to some
pretty interesting places one of the
topics discussed was actually roblox yes
roblox apple tried to argue that roblox
was an experience whereas fortnite was
strictly a game this would have helped
apple argue that they've been consistent
with the app store rules regarding games
contrary to that epic tried to argue
that fortnite wasn't a game but rather
an experience in the hopes that the
trial would shift away from games to the
wider app store in general where they'd
have better grounds to fight apple
during this trial and because of this
discussion roblox decided to rebrand
their whole game as an experienced
creation tool instead of a gaming
platform in an effort to avoid breaking
apple's rules on september 10th 2021 the
judge in this case finally came to a
decision but just like everything else
in this story the decision
was complex the
185-page ruling broadly sided with apple
near the beginning the judge surmises
that quote success is not illegal the
final trial record did not include
evidence of other critical factors such
as barriers to entry and conduct
decreasing output or decreasing
innovation in the relevant market the
court does not find that it is
impossible only the epic games failed in
its burden to demonstrate apple is an
illegal monopolist the notion of success
not being illegal is something that
apple were quick to jump on in their
public statement after the ruling adding
that contrary to epic games accusations
of them being a monopolist they actually
face rigorous competition in every
segment in which they do business the
judge ruled the epic would have to pay
damages to apple for the loss of the 30
cut they would have got from in-game
fortnight purchases in the three months
before the game was removed from the app
store 30 percent of their 12.1 million
dollar revenue during that time meant
the epic would have to fork over around
3.65 million dollars to apple and that
wasn't even all of their damages so was
that it then can we all go home did
apple win well not quite if you remember
i said that the judge broadly sided with
apple but in one key area they didn't
the ruling came with a single injunction
for apple an order for them to open up
payment options to every developer on
the app store this was massive it might
not have been everything epic games was
looking for but it was a huge part of it
the judge had agreed with them that they
and others had the right to implement
their own payment systems in any of
their apps on the app store apple had
been given 90 days to comply with the
order the ball was now in their court on
twitter tim sweeney said that fortnite
would return to the ios store when they
would be allowed to offer their own
in-app payment for the game and also
mean a little bit about using apple pay
for the six million dollars they've been
ordered to pay but the dust didn't have
long to settle on all of this because on
september 22nd tim sweeney took to
twitter yet again to share another twist
in the story he said apple lied apple
spent a year telling the world the court
and the press they'd welcome epic's
return to the app store if they agree to
play by the same rules as everyone else
epic agreed and now apple has reneged in
another abuse of its monopoly power over
a billion users he then shares an
alleged email he'd sent to apple
executive phil schiller in which he
tells him that epic will adhere to
apple's guidelines that they've paid the
damages and that they're willing to
bring fortnight back to ios once apple
follows the court order to allow them to
include alternative purchasing
mechanisms within fortnite this was
followed by what tim sweeney alleges to
be an email from apple dated september
22nd the email essentially used the
court's rulings to back up the decision
that apple had made that fortnight would
not be returning to the app store until
quote the district court's judgment
becomes final and unappealable tim
sweeney said that this black listing
meant that apple could go through every
appeal process in order to delay the
court order which could take up to five
years so where the hell are we now then
well both sides had rulings that went in
their favor and both sides will be
appealing the rulings that didn't go in
their favor that's fairly normal the
appeals process is part of the justice
system but it means that after over a
year of fighting that got incredibly
petty at times we still don't have a
resolution we may still have to wait to
see how the apple vs epic fight ends but
either way the repercussions could be
huge even that single injunction that
compels apple to allow developers to
have their own in-app purchase systems
could have a massive effect the app
store is one of apple's biggest assets
the profits they make on those 30
transaction cuts are absurdly big will
we see the end of that in the future
will epic continue to suffer for every
day that fortnight isn't on the app
store only time will tell one thing's
for sure
both of these companies will go down
swinging
re-brand their whole game as an
experienced creation tool to otherwise a
leather
an experience creation tool
that's like a like football comment
commentator from the 80s well not quite
remember
well not quite
so
was that it then did
so was that it then did everything
come on
so was that it then can we all go home
did apple win well
can help what do i say well not quite